بالنسبة إلى الموقع الأثري الأكثر تميزًا
في سريلانكا ، ستحتاج إلى البحث عن
طريق أعلى
[موسيقى]
تقع على ارتفاع 660 قدمًا فوق
هضبة صخرية في منطقة ماتال بسري
لانكا ، حيث توجد أطلال قلعة من القرن الخامس
قام الملك بتشكيل شكل
وحجم الصخور البارزة
من الغابة أدناه تم إنشاؤه بواسطة
حمم صلبة من بركان خامد
يعود إلى عصور ما قبل التاريخ ، أصبح التكوين الصخري
معروفًا
باسم seguidilla أو صخرة الأسد بعد
الحجر الكبير  يجب أن يستعد الأسد الذي وضع علامة
على مدخل الدرج للزوار الذين
يتسلقون إلى القمة
للخطوات الـ1200 التي سيستغرقونها لتوسيع نطاق
سيجيريا لصرف الانتباه عن التسلق الحاد ،
ويمكن للزوار دراسة
اللوحات الجدارية التي يبلغ عمرها 1500 عام والتي تم رسمها على طول الصخور
في الأعلى.  بقايا مهجورة
لقلعة الملوك بالإضافة إلى
منظر رائع لما يُعتقد
أنه بعض أقدم الحدائق ذات المناظر الطبيعية
في العالم ، إنه تسلق طويل ولكن بمجرد
وصولك إلى القمة ، ستشهد
يشار إليه من قبل السكان المحليين على أنه
الأعجوبة الثامنة في العالم
[موسيقى]